in about two weeks clark county will
fully reopen we heard that from
commissioners yesterday
it's a major milestone as we come out of
the pandemic something that we've been
missing is live entertainment on fremont
street in the city
well that's coming back too bianca
holman is live this afternoon with
reaction from visitors bianca
[Applause]
downtown is known for its unique eats
its boutique casinos and hotels
and live music on these six blocks right
behind me
now at the top of next month visitors
will have a full downtown las vegas
experience again
on june 1st at midnight friedman street
experience will activate all three
stages with free music
due to covet restrictions these stages
have been empty
they've sat empty for the past year we
spoke with locals and tourists and they
tell us they're excited about the return
of live music
because it'll bring more foot traffic to
small businesses and provide
opportunities for those in the music
industry to perform
well i've been here since this place was
not consistent
of music and it was like once a year
like a big band would come so now it's
like
24 7. it's important i think it's
extremely important i'm glad it's going
to be open 100 percent
when it was covered we couldn't make no
money but now it's back
now we can make our money back again
and when it comes to copa 19 guidelines
the fremont street experience states on
their website they will follow
the governor's declarations now no word
yet on
who was set to perform that
entertainment list will come out next
week
reporting from downtown bianca holman 8
news now